the 49ers embarking on this seven game
death march and it begins on sunday
night against the rams i can't recall a
team facing that many contenders that
many great teams in a row
without a break they have a buy but they
don't get a cupcake along the way
it is great team after great team
starting with the rams we'll do fill in
the blank now
from the rams 49ers game sunday night on
nbc blank
is currently the most concerning issue
for the 49ers what do you say
uh defensive health it's tempting to say
jimmy garoppolo
and i almost would say jimmy garoppolo
but to me
the pass rush isn't the same obviously
without bosa
coverage isn't the same obviously
without richard sherman
and when i look at what's coming down
the road mike
and i don't see richard sherman in
great health and i see even bit players
or lesser players i should say
like solomon thomas gone you know role
players
you know we're in week five of the
season
and it almost feels like injury-wise
on defense for the 49ers it feels like
it's week 15
and you're limping toward the finish i
agree with you that the health is a
major issue
although let me add this there was an
item on the nbc sports bay area website
i wrote something about it before the
show today
jennifer lee chan is the author on it uh
george
kittle pointing out yesterday that he
actually called joe
staley who's now retired for advice on
what the hell to do
because the leadership isn't there like
it was
staley's not there sherman's not there
and and and i think kittle is embracing
the fact that he's got to kind of be a
jerk
and he's got to get in people's faces
and tell them that better performance
is demanded of them even if they are
replacing someone who's injured you know
early on i thought this would be like
the patriots
where it's next man up there's no
excuses and they demand and get
the same level of performance from the
replacement that they had from the
injured starter that's not happening
and i feel like kiddo and i credit him
for talking about it and doing it
kittle looks like he's inching toward
being the guy who's going to be the one
who demands that these replacements
play better than they have because
that's one of the big reasons they're
two and three and that two and three is
going to get out of control quickly
peter
as these next seven games unfold if they
don't start winning some
uh game soon arizona and dallas get
together
monday night under andy dalton the
cowboys offense will what peter
continue to be good enough to win but it
may not matter
i mean you know look jerry jones spent
this money in the off-season on andy
dalton
and when he did i remember saying look
dak prescott's been an iron man mostly
but
but you know getting a good backup
quarterback
is great because you just never know
and so to me i look at andy dalton right
now
and i say andy dalton is going to
continue to put up
28 33 points a game he's got a great
supporting cast
he doesn't have a great offensive line
but he's got a great supporting cast
otherwise so i look at this and i say
it is all dependent on a defense
that is playing at a historically bad
level averaging 36 points a game given
up
the two games that they've won as ed
werder said uh earlier
in our bumper mic they've won on field
goals at the buzzer
basically uh and and had to score 40 and
37 points
to do it so to me i kind of look at
the dallas cowboys and say i mean
obviously
you're glad that that andy dalton is
there
he's going to be good enough it may not
matter though in saving the cowboys
season
if they keep giving up 36 points a game
i agree with everything you said let me
reiterate a point that i made earlier
this week though having dak
out for the year reduces the
expectations
maybe enough that the cowboys can
breathe a little bit
and i don't think they're going to be
dramatically worse without dak because
again the offense
isn't the major problem it's the defense
but but maybe
that that just overwhelming urgency that
ramps up
every year we all know jerry jones wants
to be able to say
we want a super bowl with the team that
i built not not a team someone else
built it's my
team and every year there's a greater
sense of urgency because he knows
there's only so many years
left that he can try and and i just feel
like they
they load the cannon they create the
expectation
he's so available to the media not as
much this year as in past years but he
still does that
twice a week on 105 3 the fan in dallas
stephen jones
is on there multiple times a week and
it's just always there
and i think now that some of the air has
been taken out of the balloon
maybe some of these guys can just play
football and just and not
and not have that overwhelming sense of
we must win and we must win right now
yeah i think that's a great way to look
at it mike and you would hope
that that is going to be something that
helps them but
i'll tell you this you know you've got a
really
explosive offense coming to dallas for
this game
you got kyler murray who for some reason
this week mike
seems to be a little bit motivated like
baker mayfield was
about coming home to texas and kyler
murray now could be the first
guy could be the first guy to win
as a high school player in jerry world
as a college player
in jerry world and then as a pro player
in jerry world
i realize that everybody around the
country and
and in great britain or whoever is
watching us
is saying who really cares well people
play high school football in texas they
care
they care a lot and so i i think i think
it motivates kyle murray it motivates
cliff kingsbury
to go into dallas and to try to win a
game so
they are going to get an explosive
offense
and look it you know the the
accomplishment of this week
in my opinion will be if the cowboys can
hold
arizona under 30 points and i know that
sounds absurd
but to me that would be a tremendous
accomplishment
to old deandre hopkins uh kenyon drake
who's been hasn't had a great year so
far
and uh kyler murray under 30 would be a
great accomplishment in my opinion
that would be a winning formula for
dallas my biggest regret
in picking games this year was not
accounting for that texas angle when the
browns
who will only play there once every
eight years
bring miles garrett back to where he
grew up
baker mayfield's back otto beckham jr
back against the cowboys again after
those battles
when he was with the giants and i wish i
would have put more stock in that
because that
clearly and stefanski told me after the
game that it means some
factor they stepped up in that moment
and and i think the cardinals are going
to do the same because kyler murray is
going to tell them we're all going to go
out there and show what we can do on
this stage in texas
all right the bears and the panthers the
bears four and one
rode underdogs against the panthers who
are supposed to be
bad this year but they're three and two
the panthers offense is clicking without
christian mccaffrey
that can be attributed to what peter
uh the the ability
of matt rule to convince
players who are not great players that
we have a standard here and if you play
in this game
it's up to you to meet that standard
classic case
you know they have lost so many top
players
basically and i'm not just talking about
christian mccaffrey in week two
i'm talking about you know teddy
bridgewater has to play to the
kind of classic standard of cam newton
shaq thompson has to take that
mantle you know from even though he's a
different
player and a different style of player
from luke lee
he's got to become the leader uh
you know on that on that defense and so
i kind of look at
what has been inculcated in the players
on this team in the first training camp
and in the first month of this season
and say
that matt rule is working the same
and i don't want to call it magic the
same ethos
on the carolina panthers early on as he
worked
at baylor when they were coming back
from an impossible situation
at temple when temple never won games
and he accomplished it in both places
and he's accomplishing it
right now in charlotte north carolina
sooner than anyone
ever would have expected and i think
teddy bridgewater is one of the big
reasons why
they are they are getting it done
without mccaffrey all right real quickly
bengals colts if it happens philip
rivers job security is what
one week away from being tenuous one of
the reasons
is that frank reich really really likes
uh jacoby brissette and would not have a
fear
of making this move but he also brought
philip rivers in and they paid him 25
million bucks
i i think they're gonna be a little bit
slow with the hook mike
hard to admit the mistake when you've
made that investment the jets and the
dolphins getting together the dolphins
are favored to win for the first time in
the brian flores
tenure at nine and a half points
assuming that they win a three and three
dolphins team is
what a threat to win the division
i picked him to win the division before
the season and
i didn't know exactly why because i
couldn't point to any single thing other
than
i saw a vastly undermanned
miami dolphins team at the end of the
season have a winning record after
halloween
and i don't know how they did it and i
look at the miami dolphins and they're
going to beat the jets and they're going
to be three and three
and they could be within one game of
first place
on monday night they are a legitimate
threat to win the division
i'll say that a three and three dolphins
team is
squandering the opportunity to get
tuatanga viloa ready for 2021 they're
gonna regret him not playing this year
when they get to next year and he's
thrown into the fray although the chiefs
didn't
when they put patrick holmes on the
field in 2018 after sitting out most of
2017.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports